bueno Comencemos por Sandra Torres ella
es quizás la más reconocida de todos los
candidatos en cada Rincón de Guatemala
ella ha sido madre hija y esposa de
políticos fue primera dama de la nación
en la presidencia de Álvaro Colón dos
veces candidata a la presidencia pasando
a segunda vuelta en el 2015 perdió
contra Jimmy Morales y en el 2019 contra
Alejandro yamatei pero al mismo tiempo
que es tan conocida es la que se dice
carga el mayor antiboto es una candidata
populista que promete erradicar la
pobreza en este país y también meter a
todos los criminales en prisión edmon
mulet también es un candidato
con mayores opciones él es un político
de larga trayectoria también diplomático
fue 12 años congresista presidente del
Congreso embajador de Guatemala en
Washington y en la Unión Europea se
planta en un espectro de Centro derecha
promete erradicar la corrupción de este
país Pero quizás una de sus promesas más
polémicas es la de conseguir 500.000
visas de empleo temporal para los
guatemaltecos en Estados Unidos en aras
de frenar el fenómeno de la migración
irregular y Suri Ríos ella es hija del
dictador fallecido de Guatemala de
Efraín Ríos montt sobre ella pesa la
sombra de su padre un dictador acusado
de genocidio indígena Quien murió en la
impunidad ella se planta en cambio en el
espectro de extrema derecha está en
contra de todo tipo de aborto está en
contra de la legalización de las drogas
y en materia de seguridad le hace un
guiño a bukele para meter a todos los
pandilleros en las cárceles esta semana
recibió el saludo de expresidentes cómo
Sebastián Piñera de chile y Álvaro Uribe
de Colombia muy probablemente dos de
estos tres pasarán a segunda vuelta con
esos son los tres candidatos más
opcionados en el país pero también se
llegó a cuestionar por ejemplo la
transparencia de las autoridades
electorales por la eliminación de otros
tres candidatos Qué pasó con ellos
bueno el que más ruido generó fue Carlos
Pineda empresario de Aviación un
candidato antisistema con más de 24
millones de me gusta en tiktok
comenzando mayo el lideraba las
encuestas a la presidencia y estaba muy
por encima de sus competidores todo un
fenómeno político muy locomulando el
discurso populista de Donald Trump en
los Estados Unidos pero de repente Fue
cancelado por el tribunal supremo
electoral arguyendo que su partido había
incurrido en irregularidades en la
celebración de las asambleas para
elegirlo a él o proponerlo a él como
candidato a la presidencia otra
candidata que también fue cancelada para
muchos censurada estas elecciones fue
Thelma Cabrera líder indígena recordemos
en un país donde cerca del 50% de su
población es indígena ella de izquierda
fue
fue puesta por fuera de esta de esta
contienda electoral en contra a razón de
un proceso en contra de su fórmula
vicepresidencial Jordán Rodas ex
procurador de los Derechos Humanos en
los tiempos de la sisija cuando
Guatemala destacaba por ser un país que
luchaba en contra de la corrupción y
finalmente Roberto arzú del fin político
hijo de Roberto arzú quien tenía un
discurso muy fuerte contra Alejandro
yamatei y fue excluido por campaña
extemporánea